guys good news and bad news bad news is
you cannot see me on the road any longer
doing my material because I finished my
special and it will be coming out in the
spring of 24 thank you Chicago you are
amazing here's the good news when I'm
not doing my solo tour I'm doing the
group tour so come see me and the guys
from impr practical jokers to our kicks
off in just a couple of weeks in January
we're in Highland California we're in
Vegas baby at Resorts World Theater and
then at the mullet arena in Tempe
Arizona then we got the impractical
Joker's Cruz with Eric Andre and a ton
of other people Felipe Esparza steveo
Adam Ray um just a ton of great stuff
happened on that one and there still are
some cabins left it's our fifth one it's
going to be insane get shipfaced tocom
or shipfaced
cruise.com come along that's January
22nd to the 26th from there we go to
Florida we're doing the Hard Rock in
Hollywood we're doing the uh seminal
Casino in Tampa and uh then the Hard
Rock Casino in Cincinnati uh then in
April Youngstown Ohio at the golli
center a couple at the Chicago theater
right there a couple at Foxwoods uh and
then in June Atlanta at the Symphony
Hall mobile Mobile Alabama at the Sanger
theater so we are going to be all over
uh check out impracticaljokers.com or
really just go to savc comedy.com to get
tickets I hope to see you guys on the
road this is the last second leg and
last leg of the Joker tour as well so
when we're done with this one Show's
retired you can't see it anymore so hope
to see you guys on the road and look out
for my special Next Year Chrissy
California that's who I am I got a show
January 12th in El Cahone AK Elon
California San Diego area Magnolia
Theater and then January 13th at the
wilter in Los Angeles these are Big
Shows this is the only time I'm going to
be in California Chris DC comedy.com for
Ticky wikies then February 2nd at the
Ryman Auditorium in Nashville which one
of I one of the most beautiful venues in
the country and then February 3rd
Washington DC and then I end everything
February 8th uh in Reno Nevada Christy
comedy.com for
tickies don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate say hey bab hey bab hey bab hey
bab hey bab hey so it's me hi I'm the
problem it's me at T time
everybody agrees I'll stare directly at
the Sun but never in the mirror it must
be exhausting always rooting for the hay
babe that sound like a
church let's do it like that though okay
all right here we go ready this is the
first time I ever heard that so I'll try
to mimic it let's do it all right you
ready yeah it's me hi I'm the problem
it's me at te time everybody agrees I'll
directly at the Sun but never in theor
must be exha always rooting for
the you did it happy New Year happy New
Year happy new year old
acquaint clearly this is the New Year's
episode new year new beer new year new
year new beard new year new bar here we
go you ready for this these are the
predictions the 2024 predictions if 5%
of these come true this is on the
internet this is going around making the
rounds at home agree I want you if
you're in the car honk the horn if you
agree if you're at home and you agree um
what uh you got real hair you got real
fingernails if you have a job you going
to school and you don't need anyone to
tell you how to handle your business you
make some noise some noise so here we go
2024 predictions we start off crazy we
start off easy and then it gets wild
Taylor Swift elopes I would say yes I
think the only way she's going to top
herself is that will send people I mean
that will drive people crazy that's it
Taylor Swift elopes with Travis Kelce
that's what they're saying and she
become Taylor Kelce Taylor K that's
interesting or does he become Travis
Swift because she's a Swifty she becomes
Travis Swift I think Swift yes and the
whole thing she'll he'll do whatever she
says Nikki Haley revealed to be a
swinger I don't know what that means
Camala Harris too who's Nikki Haley
Nikki Haley's a politician oh the one
that was like smoking weed and grow up
in the guys yes yeah okay her and Kamal
Harris revealed to be swingers did we
say yes well I could believe Nikki Hy
from the footage I've seen so far oh zic
has horrible side effects no I bet who
knows we know that they test it out how
do you know leftist leftists get really
into jamu and
cashmir I don't know what that means um
Bill Clinton
dies
possible he's the of the age wish it on
him but yeah we don't no definitely
don't wish it on him but I'm just saying
it's I hope not Ted Cruz loses we don't
know Los is what that's the thing so
that's probably definitely true he's
going to lose something oh here's a fun
one Kylie Jenner and Timothy sham get
engaged are they dating I don't know yes
they are they are is that a thing a long
time thing already yeah a long time
thing like are they serious they've been
dating since the US Open they went there
together who Vena knows Vena plays
tennis on the atoria public tennis
courts
do you oh do you have a tennis like
tennis outfit yeah you do you want to
play Let's play tennis you know let me
tell you something right now there's
tennis courts around here right now vity
is dressed as a lot
lizard I I I bought a tennis racket and
a bunch of tennis balls two tennis
rackets and a bunch of tennis balls
because where the tennis courts were
where I moved and uh I never stepped on
the court once I'm a member at a tennis
club that I paid too much money for I
haven't went to once you haven't gone I
swear to God I'm a member at a tennis
club and I haven't went once and Delilah
went once anding hates it yeah and I
I've already paid the year in full
pickle bow is more our speed now yeah
all right what can you do besides tennis
though nothing no you can go eat you can
go eat at the restaurant and if you
don't spend the money they charge your
card anyway so you have to go eat there
or you get charged it was the one of the
worst decisions I've ever made all right
Kanye West converts to
Hinduism he's he hasn't already SW was
the origin that was a Hindu symbol so
there you go Ron
s who the swastika that was an original
Hindu symbol okay it didn't mean you
know the Nazis made it course they
co-opted that as as well as the Charlie
chapl mustache yes Ron de santis cries
on national TV that would be fun for us
Joe Biden welcomes his first great
grandchild uh why would okay okay here's
here's one here's here's a coin flip Ben
afflac and Matt Damon reveal they have
had a fling in the
9s I I would I wouldn't be surprised
capri pants back in style no way they're
never coming back everybody does the
Macarena the 2024 DNC ends in violence
Jesus a hurricane hits Washington DC
okay the Senate staff for caught having
gay writes a heartfelt personal essay
that goes viral please
God silly bands come back and right
Wingers drum up a moral panic over them
what silly bands I don't know and why we
write when drum up a moral pan why did
this get political why is this polit who
who is who's made these the Twitter
somebody on Twitter Twitter made Twitter
Twitter sent it or X
yeah um I so I don't know because it is
one of those things when you come to the
end of the year first of all would you
say 2023 was a good year bad year middle
you know was it as the kids say was the
year mid for for myself or in for what I
what my my perception is for the world
mid yeah mid you know what mid means
right of course I do mid yeah I just was
talking about slanging the other day I
was mid so m i could do a lot of slang
yeah so do would you say 20 give us a
give us a 2023 slang look up the most
and let's let's see who who knows what
the most slang is we'll see it's almost
like a spelling be we'll see who knows
how to use it correctly would you say
2023 was lit or mid right you could say
that and you got also had to explain to
you what it means okay there's one
there's one like the word of the year
was Riz I know what Riz is cuz I had to
look it up because people called me a
Riz God all the time wait the word with
the wasz they said s RZ s RZ God this
and I was like I got to it's it's
basically I thought it was going to be
bad but it's not it's basically short
for charismatic
Charisma correct and I was like thank
God I was looking up like all right what
do I what's wrong with me okay and then
they thought I had Charisma so what
would you say would you say 23 was
sunglasses indoors prescription I wear
my sunglasses in the afternoon yeah Riz
so I learned RZ so you didn't you you
knew Riz but you didn't know I didn't
know Riz I I didn't know RZ I know I
know Rizza I know Riz from Greece I know
the Riz Carlton yeah the other big one
is cap cap I know cap is a lot cap I
know cuz it used to be it used to be
I'll bust a cap in your ass but cap has
now taken a different Med yeah well let
me ask you a question where did why does
cap mean lie where it come from what's
the atmology no don't show us you test
us where did cap come from yeah cap I
mean or all those you just throw at us
cap I mean we could you think we could
figure it out cap I think like like cap
is like No Cap means like I'm not lying
right but no cap but why does cap mean
lying cuz cap maybe something with caps
lock in the phone like you know like
you're C putting things on capitalizing
things state capitals I know everyone
it's tied to like the hat emoji yeah
well that's cuz that's a cap it probably
came out of a rap song to be honest yeah
says that to cap is to brag or exagger
about something so no cap probably like
No Cap lie okay no lie but why is Cap to
you know I mean why is that that I don't
know yeah wouldn't it be amazing if we
could start a slang word that got into
the zeist and people use and it becomes
part of the vernacular a lot of big
words I just said yeah I like that
vernacular zeist yeah yeah and we could
perpetuate that perpetuates a good word
here's another word I just learned tell
me what this means if I said s stop
being such an icono clast what would I
be saying you are I know the word I know
the
word but I would probably I would need
context I feel bad that I don't know the
the that's going to annoy me that I
don't know it so in icono class it means
like you're somebody who's like taking
down like higher powers like you're
taking down like like when I when on the
Christmas episode when you were dising
me you if I said you know case for
Christ and you're saying there's no way
Christ is real you're being an icon
you're being icono clastic towards
Christ which might come back and might
you might not I don't know okay so
something like that icono class was a
good word that I learned that's fun what
about the word Daft if I said you're
acting Daft what am I
saying not Daft D not like Daft Punk
like yeah like like what is Daft a
synonym for Daft would be what
Punk am I thinking of
deft Deft might be another word is is is
is it not like um which just another
word I learned uh like agile like not
agile in the sense of physical but no it
means crazy like if I was like you're
acting daap me you're acting crazy is De
to word
deft
de de that's a good I do a good de do it
Deft skillfully de I said agility but
yeah so I was think the way she was
rubbing my balls was
Deft he he was rubbing my balls the most
deaft yo okay so so D is CRA just crazy
what would you say about 2023
though um for you personally not overall
for the world personally for
me I thought it was a good
year you know I'm dealing with the same
nonsense I've I've always dealt with but
I on the whole lot of good memories good
moments um film the special um allegedly
alleged
it'll be out in the
spring um is there a year like when I
say what would you say so far in your
life has been the worst calendar year
and the best calendar year cuz there's
numbers in everybody's head like for me
I know them yeah I'd say you uh 20 and
21 were pretty bad were the worst
calendar
years yes I I would say they're in the
running for sure and it's not it's it's
not just because of the pandemic and and
you know what that did but just so many
different things but uh but yeah some of
the best yeah I I if I sat down I could
pinpoint them what is the best year what
has been the best year of your life
calendar year what is like a year you
could live and you wish you could take
2017 was sick number one year I I mean I
just off the top of my head it was it
was a really good year you got to
accomplish many goals and life goals and
dreams and stuff yeah 2017 2019 really
good years um m 2019 as well for the
best year so far really 2019 I think
there was something I could be nostalgic
about it because obviously it was the
last year preco that we had that was you
know relatively normal even though
things were still insane then we just
you know were rationalizing it better
but 2019 I just felt free I felt good I
felt um yeah I I I me too and if you go
back and look it's like I I looked even
though I was only like four years ago I
look exponentially older now I looked
younger there I looked more healthy more
vibrant
also I was coming off like a string of
good years it was like it was I was
riding High there and then we all got
chopped at the knees but like we say
like we like we've talked about many
times in this podcast the good old days
are happening right now so you will look
at yourself right now 5 years from now
and can't believe how good you look
right now so don't don't don't forget
that okay so it's always going to get
worse yeah well it's you're always
getting older so you'll always look back
in five years and be like I looked
better back then you're never as fat as
you thought you're never as old looking
as you thought as fat as I thought I'm
never as as you thought right yes I
still say this is my skinniest sale okay
all right
uh yeah I I I two was a banger was a
banger but uh and the worst year was
2020 21 my worst year was
1998 I had 98 I had a good year 2003 was
a great year 200 98 was a bad year for
me cuz I had Mono and my mom had gout
and we just ruined our year
okay but I did get cable in 1998 I do
remember that was 2010 for you guys 20
2010 2010 for me was actually good
because it's the year I graduated
physical therapy school and the year I
really started into standup comedy so
that was a good year for me that was a
year of possibility because I just got
my physical therapy degree my doctorate
I'd gotten everything and I was out
there hitting the open mic scene and
kind of discovering this new world of
Comedy so I would say 2010 was was
actually a good year for me and you
that's when the show started right 2K10
was when I got the show when we no when
we shot the pilot presentation in 2010
so that's a good year uh it's also the
year I moved out of a basement apartment
after like nine years I think the uh
2000 yeah after nine years I moved out
of a little basement studio apartment
into like a three-bedroom apartment
that's crazy you lived in a basement
studio apartment for nine years I'll do
you one better I slept on a couch I had
no mattress for nine years yeah nine
years wow from from August 2001 to July
2010 wow you never complained you were
like this is just where I live and how I
live yeah rent was great right all in
utilities included was like it was it
was crazy when I moved there was
600 and then uh there was a new landlord
right and he kept it 600 so I was like
okay cool and then and then I became
friends with him and then the next
landlord came and as a favor he told the
new landlord that my rent was 550 so if
my landlord raised it 50 bucks it'd be
the same again nice the next landlord
didn't raise it okay hold on there's
more now there's an enter the fourth
landlord I became friends with the third
he did the same thing for me and the
last landlord didn't raise it so over
the nine years I started at 600 rent
went down to 550 and then went down to
500 when I left 500 Rent All in
utilities included come on come on you
were B Money yeah Bank you had more
money in your bank account then than you
do today I was saving like nobody's Biz
like nobody's Biz I mean I had my
computer in the kitchen but still but
whatever you dealt with it yeah I dealt
dealt with and you didn't think of it
any other way no I liked it it was cozy
I decorated the way I want somehow had
enough storage the kitchen was big even
though the place was small like a
hostage I had a desk in a lot of my
kitchen exactly I was living like a cell
a lot of my uh a lot of my kitchen
cabinets housed like like what would be
in closets but you ever have a a rat or
or a roach don't lie um no I did have
one of those thousand leg silverfish
type jammies I saw one of those MFS one
time cuz it was a basement apartment it
was but I did have half window window
like almost full siiz windows so that
was also nice so you actually had a
garden apartment then you didn't have a
basement you had a Gard was the basement
but it but if you had half windows I
think the real estate people the good
people at Red fer Zilla would list that
as a garden apartment okay CU you have a
full somewhat of a full size window safe
light repair replace so why did you
bring up 2010 pimp what was significant
about that for you nothing I just
thought it was a cool year right I'm
sorry for 2004 I don't know it Ruben
stutter oh The Velvet Teddy Bear yeah
I'm sorry for 2004 you never heard that
song No I but I how but how amazing is
it that I knew he was the velvet teddy
bear hold on he wrote we've played it he
wrote who did oh we did okay okay who
did he do you remember this so I so I
did hear it and I forgot it again yeah
who did he beat uh to become the
American Idol Klay Aken Klay Aken
absolutely right and by the way zero
hesitation by pimp zero I'd vote for him
he should run for president I did you
ever a did you were you ever a fan of
American Idol yeah when when it first
came out and they when they were mean
like they showed people like first
unreal
[Music]
yeah but were you ever a fan enough to
vote I was such a fan I watched the
awful movie they made after season one
you did they made a movie Kelly and
Justin oh right Justin guino yeah gu
yeah no gu guini guini guini I think
Kelly Clarkson is the only one who made
it out of the FR I met Kelly Clarkson
have you ever gone on a show she's a
sweetheart uh no I've never I've never
I've never met her I've never met Drew
Barrymore never met Drew Barrymore but I
went on KY Clarkson a couple times she
was real deal sweet she's as advertised
I was on that day I do I told you the
story I think I might have told you it
we go on that day and we're one of three
guests okay we're the first guests on
the second guest is no there's four
guests with the first guest the SEC hey
guys if you new here you are uh hearing
me talk about better he for the first
time but if not you know that this
podcast guys is sponsored by better help
um and if you never tried therapy I
would say to give it a try uh from my
own personal experience it has helped me
through some of the toughest points of
my life and it also just helps me in my
day to day a lot of people think that
you go to therapy for these like you
know huge things and have huge
Revelations and M that might happen but
it's also to just kind of just be at
your tiptop mental shape and process
things dayto day you know um and reflect
I think it's important to reflect so you
can do that with better help uh very
easily because it is entirely online
it's designed to work around your
schedule it's completely flexible you go
online you fill out a brief
questionnaire they match you with a
therapist you can switch therapists at
any time um if you're thinking of trying
it this is an easy way in guys and you
know it is the holidays right now and it
is a stressful time we're seeing our
family we're running around buying gifts
for people a lot of times we're not
thinking of ourselves uh and I got to
tell you you need to take that minute to
to think about yourself um I think about
that more now but when I was younger
running around I didn't and so this is
the knowledge I'm imparting on you young
folk that are watching this podcast it's
the season of giving so give yourself
what you need with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com heyab to get 10% off your
first month that's
betterhelp.com
heyab guys we have a new sponsor called
Dr Squatch and this is uh natural soaps
and I was sent these when they signed on
and I was sent the whole line of scents
and I got to tell you there isn't one
dud in the batch I was thrilled they
smell amazing and it made me realize how
crappy my soap was that I actually was
using it just makes me feel good about
myself okay um let's let's talk about
some things no harmful ingredients in
this okay it's the century experience
I'm telling you right now it's uh B
corpse certified so Google that if you
don't know what that means because I
don't have the time right now um one of
Dr squatch's founding missions is to
encourage men to pay attention to the
ingredients they use on your body women
pay attention all the time a woman knows
what a woman puts on a woman's body a
man does not know what a man puts on a
man's body and you can quote me on that
and put it on my stone um here's some of
the products they have cool fresh aloe
soap pinear soap fresh Falls which I'm
holding my hand Bay Rum soap wood barrel
Bourbon Birchwood Breeze which is my
favorite and uh also you can get a soap
saver so right now Dr Squatch is
offering our listeners a huge savings
all new customers will get three free
bar of soaps plus three free bars of
soap it's spelled bar of soaps so plus
free shipping with any purchase of three
bars just go to drsquatch.com
to receive this buy three get three
offer that's Dr Squatch D RSQ ach.com
to babe to buy three soaps and get three
free it's time to get all the daily
routine Essentials you'll need to start
feeling good and smelling like a man
today okay the
we're the first guest on the second
guest is no there's four guests we're
the first guest the
SEC Austin the Gilmore Girls I don't
know who was first or second then the
the third guest we're sitting out there
and in her show you stay out there you
don't leave so the guests just keep
getting added on and the third guest was
going to be somebody who uh had cancer
or had a loved one die of cancer or
something like that and they were going
to talk about this serious serious stuff
and she's like we were told by The
Producers you just guys stay out you
know but do your thing you know because
it's like it's a heavy subject matter so
we wouldn't mind if you made you know
made it like light and I was just like
I'm sorry I'm not going to try to make
light of any situation that's about to
happen right now so we just sat out
there and the person stood up from that
chair and told this horrific story about
something that was so bad that involved
like death and Trauma and sadness and I
none of us even made a peep right and
then funny and then Roy Choy the chef oh
yeah amazing I'm a huge Roy chy fan he
was coming out for a cooking segment I'm
a Choy Boy he was coming out for a
cooking that's good thank you he was
coming out for a a cooking segment after
that right after we heard about everyone
dying from the cancer and we had
pre-made stations and we were going to
cook with him and and I am a huge fan
and and they said look all right you
didn't say anything for the lady with
the cancer whatever but like with Roy
Choy like this is famously act it up do
whatever you want be zany crazy you
don't know how to cook the food like
this is what they're telling us and I'm
like all right I don't really want to
mess anything up really though so we get
out there Roy Troy comes out I mean this
guy's a g you know who he is he he's a
real G he's like the the the the
Godfather the food truck but he's like
oh yes but he's a cool ass dude he's
like our age he's got like a lot of Swag
and he's just like he's known for real
like anyway enough about him Google he
comes out and I don't really want to be
like that guy but the other guys in the
show with like M and everything like
they went full-blown and like they just
started like you know lighting a fire
and dropping [__] and everything
and it I felt so guilty because it was
really like overtaking like I I didn't
want to do that I wanted to just cook it
real like you know he was good enough
and so I started getting like pretty
embarrassed and mortified and then at
one point during the whole thing he like
literally turned to us like on the air
like all right guys enough like you did
yours let me do mine you you said enough
or something like that and I was like oh
my God like he did not like you guys
like he said it politely but he did say
it he was like all right guys come on
you you you you had your fun let me do
what I have to do here and I was like oh
my God and I want to be like tell them
like they literally told us to do this I
didn't want to do this but I didn't
really do much of it and then it was
over I went to Commercial and then we
had to say goodbye and I was going to
tell him how much I like him but I was
so nervous that he was mad and had a bad
opinion of me and I was intimidated by
him and so when he went to say goodbye I
was like oh thank you it's so nice to
meet you I'm a huge fan and then for
some reason I don't know why just
I would have done it to anyone but it
was bad timing I was like thank you so
much you know like you know when you say
what are you doing describe what he's
doing for the audio audience I I I like
you know he did the Chinese bow
no hold on a second it's also it's also
good ubiquitous for just like hey thanks
L like the hands the Emoji of the hands
right like I kind of I I kind of was
like thank you so much like that but
instead sorry I kind of was like like
like I wanted to be like like you know
thank you but I guess I just was like
like thank you and then I and I
literally as I did I go oh my God like I
hope he knows I just meant like like
have you ever done that before ever like
I've done this like you know like that
you know what I'm saying you've done
that yeah I don't I don't I don't I
don't I don't I don't I don't I don't I
don't practice it I don't practice it
but from afar like if you were right if
you were right here I would like right
but if someone's like far away and I was
like oh you got you got Sal's bowing at
the room I didn't bow I didn't bow but
for some reason I bowed to him but I
think it was like cuz I was intimidated
by him and I was like bowing down to him
but it was unfortunate that I also did
the appreciation hands and that combined
looked like an Asian bow what did he do
I I he just was like all right you know
like nothing like he didn't even didn't
register at least to me him like I don't
think anything but I think I was hyper
inside my own head because I was already
feeling so guilty and scared you did
that and then mer came out and you hit a
Gong I
know she was just peeing in all the coke
no you should get him on the show yeah I
mean I I we Choy boys I I mean I I truly
love the guy he he's he uh helped uh
favro make Chef the movie Chef I love he
had his own show when Chef uh Fabro had
that cooking show Roy came up look this
guy is just the coolest dude I feel like
we'd be really good friends he's also a
straight shooter listen if you're
watching Ro Troy and we know that you
are uh everything about you for me is a
10 out of 10 and I he probably doesn't
even remember that day and doesn't even
know who I am anymore but on the off
chance it struck a chord with him and
there some some tastes left in his mouth
from that they told us to do that we
didn't mean to interrupt your segment I
was thrilled to meet you I think I got
nervous and that was an appreciation
hands that had a bow attached to it they
weren't together and that wasn't
intended to be any sign of a genuflect
in a culture that I'm not a part of
someone who might be in that culture
that was not that stop the Asian hate
yeah stop it which is what we've done
stop it so John fav's father lives
across the street from
me now what are you talking about now
John that should be the name of this
episode John V he's from Queens John
Fab's father lives across the street
from how you know the lady who owns a
restaurant John Fab's father lives
across the street from me the lady who
runs the restaurant told me will they
allow it is there a c is there a cap ah
God darn it God second I think you
should
leave can you can you write dot dot dot
then finish the rest of it in the the in
the body uh it's it it'll be a mess okay
all right all right John favell's father
lives across street have you met him no
wait why did that come up from the lady
in the restaurant because she found out
that I did comedy and she goes oh I know
a guy who's involved in comedy I said
who she goes John fao's father I said is
he involved in comedy she goes no but
he's his son's John
faell and she said that he he uh he
lived he lived there too for a little
while and made the journey that he made
from Los Angeles came from that
apartment building she said she
remembers the day he was leaving to go
to La and then he went on to go make
swingers sh I thought he went to Chicago
and then went there or maybe she said he
remembers the day left New York yeah
yeah cuz he went to study like in
Chicago and that's where he met Vince
vaugh he met Vince vaugh on Rudy oh
right Rudy yeah yeah do you guys know
Rudy do you know the movie Rudy great
movie yeah it's it's more than that
though like it it was it was the biggest
movie like no one talks about it anymore
was it was nobody talks about it and
wasn't it the guy the guy it was an all
time yes
sha McKenzie sha he was in um the movie
with the uh 1980s and uh the demons
stranger things yeah Sean he was Bob
Sean Sean as and he had a brother who
was also a hard throb at the time they
were in all the Tiger Beat teen beat
stuff yes why do you love this movie why
is it the question well the movie is uh
it's an it was an instant classic and it
is in the annals of sports movie history
as one of the most inspiring like the
miracle uh on 34th Street best sports
movies Rudy Mighty Ducks and He Got Game
I like to he those are the best ones
best sex scene ever Jesus Shuttlesworth
um getting recruited and him and Rick
Fox they just are banging chicks at some
school in the South look it up look it
up Jesus Shuttlesworth that and the
Mighty Ducks the story of the children
yes get a hockey team Mighty Ducks is
awesome yeah but Rudy is like you can't
watch it and not cry right have you ever
watched Rudy not cry no you ever watchy
you haven't seen it you didn't cry no
did you watch Rudy I watched it when I
was a kid like was it was it two was it
I think I mean cuz the you know Vana
cried at My Big Fat Greek
Wedding I didn't see that you've never
seen My Big Fat Greek wding we've
covered that but I've never seen it no
should I I think you should I heard the
third one is not great but the first one
is amazing first one's good okay yeah it
got it was like I never seen The
Godfather you talked about that yeah
yeah yeah that's crazy that's on par I
think me not seeing the Godfather is in
the same My Big Fat Greek as you not
seeing My Big Fat Greek no no The
Godfather is on afi's top like 100
movies of all time time Big Fat Greek
Wedding is on uh Athens
top and
Historia yeah you got a big uh Greek
contingent over there right where I'm at
yeah I've got a lot of Greeks you got a
lot of Greek a lot of problems you got
you got and you have you have access to
a lot of good uh different food oh yeah
got a lot Cuisines Cuisine let me tell
you something let me tell you something
right now I'm prepared to say this on
this podcast now I have to travel to
this C shout out Cuisine shout out
Cuisine I don't live I don't live in the
area but I have to travel to this Cafe
but I make it a point to travel to this
Cafe daily the farest Cafe in uh I think
it's Forest Hills are you taking it up
with them now I'm take I'm telling you
I'm taking it up with the farest Cafe
that's an issue for me and I'll take up
that issue with Bloom Cafe Bloom Cafe
Bloom I will tell you there's this is
not a competition with Bloom Cafe cuz
Bloom Cafe is the best cafe on Staten
Island but now if we're moving to
another burrow I will tell you that in
the burrow of Queens which is a big
burrow it's almost the size of Rhode
Island yeah it is that's not a fact well
it could be a fact population wise I bet
you it's the same size as Rhode Island a
lot of reptilians yep farest Cafe is
unbelievable some of the best coffee
I've ever had the best they have a thing
called a crawle it's like a croissant
waffle amazing um amazing doing that now
they mix breeds of foods oatmeal is
flavored with dates flavored with dates
and it's amazing it's owned by uh I had
I had a couple dates last week there you
go no I'm not being aoke like I had
couple of like literal dates and I
haven't had dates in quite some time
this oatmeal is flavored with dates so
it's healthy for you Forest Cafe uh I
think it's on 68th Avenue or Road in
Queens unbelievable take it up with them
love them love the people they are
amazing great people you really do go to
places and you cultivate and you find
you and you make yourself a part of the
community always very nice to me very a
collective group of people in there all
different types of people it's really
dope I love I love living there and
living I go to that place all the time
and they coffee literally tastes
fantastic and it gives me nice
sustainable energy and it's owned by
Chinese people like Roy Choy oh God
bless
um how does the sun give you vitamin D
the sun gives you vitamin D because of
the ultraviolet rays what it does is it
causes some type of thermogenic reaction
in your cells and then the byproduct of
that is vitamin D so it's producing
vitamin D just from itself so if you
were if you didn't eat for like one
month and you went out in the sun you'd
be
getting vitamin D I told you you don't
have to eat for 30 days and you can
survive you just have to drink
water that's what that's what you got to
do so back to my question then if you
didn't eat for 30 days and you survived
and you drank water and then you went in
the sun you'd get vitamin D or is
vitamin D playing off nutrients we're
getting from other food I I want to say
that you bringing it out like did I get
my vitamin D from like a Ste bring them
out bring them out it's hard to yell
when the vitamin D is in your mouth is
that what he says Barrel it says Barrels
in your mouth oh barel like we were
talking about put a French a on or
something sounds nice a barel a barrel
um vitamin D that's how I think vitamin
D is made I could be wrong but it
sounded right oh so you don't know you
just have to confidently give an answer
and then people say it sounds right cuz
even when you talk to like scientists
like they're just going to confidently
tell you what it is but I don't know
that it's right or wrong but if I told
you that taking their word that they did
the research I said thermogenic I said
when you said thermogenic I was all in
I'm like you he knows the answer how are
you going to debate that oh so
thermogenic was just something you
pulled out of your hole no thermogenic
is a real word that I remember from
physical therapy school and I do think
it's involved in the vitamin D process
but I'm not 100% but I sounded confident
and I had two feet on the floor mentally
not physically cuz my left foot I have
an Achilles issue but I had two feet on
the floor mentally and I stood in it and
I and I was so confident I believe you
that I think I could swing you you no I
believed you but at the end of the day
what you said was that the
sun makes vitamin D you didn't really
well the ultraviolet R of the Sun causes
a thermogenic reaction in your C where
the byproduct being vitamin D we don't
know though how that happened
we just accept even even as as as you
and we we we hear from the people that
are telling us that and we only
understand up to a certain amount and
then we still have no ideas how still
right we just take it and believe it and
we we then regurgitate just the portion
that we are capable of that we know
right right but there's a whole you just
said a very broad thing but like this
right you know what I mean hey what am I
some broad some you know what broad is
you know why that's like you know what
that's sing for women fat ass do you
know what what broad is I believe broad
I looked this up once I believe broad
was a reference an old reference to beef
or meat and I believe that was used to
refer to vagina but I'm not positive but
we will have V look it up um that's
funny what is witch hazel and why is it
called that what what is witch hazel and
why is it called that witch hazel is um
a form of a uh it's a um like antiseptic
it cleans wounds and stuff so why is it
called witch hazel
yeah we'll look broad up I want to say
because put witch hazel in the queue
what I want to say is why it's called
witch hazel because it might have been
used for medicinal purposes that that
time they thought did wonders and they
couldn't explain it so anything that
couldn't be explained was just thought
of as witchcrafts oo not bad that's
pretty good what do you think they would
observe it observe if the branch twisted
dipped which they believe signal that
they had found water this practice was
called water witching and led to the
plant's common named witch hazel there
you go that's another word Sor which
Hazel is a plant I guess
so look that's what it looks like I
didn't I didn't know that do you ever
hear the theory with the witches Salem
witches that there was actually a root
growing in all the vegetables in the
Salem and kind of Whole New England area
at that time and the same thing in
France when they both had their uh witch
trials that there was a root growing
that specifically targeted the brain
chemistry of uh I think menting women um
and and and would make them kind of act
irrational and crazy uh because of this
root and then that's what they thought
and then and then the man was saying
well that you're witches and they and it
was really just a weed like a noxious
weed that was growing that's a big
mishap then it's wild right yeah yeah I
think [__] like that happens more than
we think I think there's literally
something in the water or the food and
it makes a groups of people act I'm I'm
telling you the overwhelming amount of
EV Google tonight I want you to go home
and just Google brain gut connection the
science is overwhelming that it's all
linked it's as link like they think your
mind and your memories even are in your
stomach like this whole idea of the
brain the brain is the brain but like
this whole idea of like the parts of the
brain we can't yeah look at that I know
you eating your literally eating your
feelings
that's it's a it's a true thing okay I'm
going to continue this pattern I'm
asking you a question that I don't know
and hear what you truly believe it is or
feel free to volue one back go ahead if
you if like to you ask me one more and
then in the now that I know that the
pressure's on me I'm going to think of a
good one to ask you
okay why is it called
shakery why is it called
shuder I don't actually know at all but
I would assume that it's a some type of
French word that means meat that's what
I would think okay that's that's why I
would still we're still looking waiting
for
broad but why
shakeri I might have stopped me if I've
asked you this on the podcast why is it
called Knocked Up have we talked about
that knocked
up I don't know yes shy comes from two
French words chair which means flesh
and C which means cooked while you may
travel around Europe you may find shark
Critter types of shops hold on share sh
share which means flesh oh so not chair
sh right so whatever it is means flesh
and cooked so it's so so that sounds
less appealing then to drop it on the
thing and say I got you a nice cooked
flesh board you you want to say Shakur
cuz you don't want to say what it really
is also isn't shakuri not
cooked guys I love game time game time
is an app that helps you get the best
tickets at the last minute and it is
super simple they guarantee their
pricing uh they have a game time
guarantee which is in fact that if you
if you uh find tickets in the same
section and row for Less game time will
credit you
110% of the difference um it's awesome
you can get a view from the seat that
you purchased H and I think that's
priceless honestly um there's things
called Zone deals where like you will
pick the game and the section you want
to be in and they pick the seat and
that's huge savings there it's it's
Flash Deals at the last second so you
don't have to like plan ahead so much
you don't have to think that you closed
out if the thing's going on really soon
and you didn't you didn't get it yet and
it's across theater and sports and
comedy and music so check out game
time uh take the guest work out of
buying tickets with Game Time download
the game time app create an account and
use code hey babe for $20 off your first
purchase terms apply again create an
account redeem code hey babe h y b a for
$20 off download the game time app today
last minute deals lowest price
guaranteed what's up guys let's talk
about
hellofresh with hellofresh you get farm
fresh pre-portion ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep skip trips to the grocery store
and count on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it's America's number one meal kit
um I just got a package a couple weeks
ago uh not even one that I uh bought
from them which I used their service but
they sent me just like a promo holiday
package with some of the new recipes in
it we had a friends gathering for the
holiday and we used their recipes and
their food and we had uh and it was just
delightful and we didn't have to worry
about going and and getting everything
and what everybody wanted we just were
like let's just everything sounded
delicious we tried it and so another
successful gathering for me with
hellofresh uh what could I tell you
about hellofresh fresh okay H well it's
not just dinner okay they they have free
uh they have breakfast as a matter of
fact they're giving all subscribers free
breakfast for life that means you'll
enjoy a totally free breakfast item with
every single hellofresh delivery that is
worth waking up for I mean am I right
okay um let's see what about some
resolutions you resolve to actually sit
down and eat dinner around the table
which is what I did but what do you do
about those nights when your schedule is
packed turn to helloof Fresh's lineup of
quick and easy meals including their
15-minute recipes designed to help
minimize Meal Time stress can't say
enough about it um go to hellofresh.com
heyab free and use code heyab free for
free breakfast for Life One breakfast
item for a box while subscription is
active go to hellofresh.com heyab free
and use code heyab free for free
breakfast for Life One breakfast item
per box while subscription is active
that's free breakfast for life at
hellofresh.com heyab free with code hey
bab
free helloof fresh America's number one
meal kit yeah I also isn't shakuri not
cooked yeah cooked it's like cured right
they say it like I guess they cooked it
cured okay all right right yeah oh how
about this cooked flesh how about this
why why can you when you get um a um
what beef tartar that's cold beef how
come you don't get sick what is the
reason why you don't get sick from beef
tartar I am what's the reason I imagine
that it's
a high
quality High highest of
quality right it's the high are you
saying it's Tartar and kpacho not the
same thing because kpacho is when it's
pounded down to little but I think it's
the same premise yeah right right right
because what happens is is when when you
get beef tartar or I think a Carpaccio
they never take it from anywhere near
like the inner cavities of the cow so
there could be no aoli in it they would
take it from like its upper back great
but who's doing who's running a coli
test from now these days like who's how
does the chef know that there's no a
coli in that because the the chances are
very low and but you're right the
highest quality meat that's when you go
to a fancy smcy restaurant same thing
with sush you go to these fancy shy
restaurants like you can't get the beef
tartar from CVS you can't do it no you
can't do that cuz you don't know where
the hell that's from you can't you can't
you can't you can't trust me don't do it
it pimp don't do it when you leave here
don't do it as soon as you leave here
you crazy pimp don't do it as soon as
you leave it then coight and let us know
the results don't do it they boil it
they boil the meat and then they drop it
into a bucket of ice for like a few
seconds what are we on tart this is
Broad I'm coming to you about broad okay
they Bo they I mean not for nothing they
boil the meat then drop into they boil
the flesh then drop into ice water and
then they put rpes around it I'm going
to ask you a hard question that seems
like it could be easy but it's really
hard if you can if you can think about
what was the best moment of 2023
specifically for you first thing that
comes to mind go with that what is
it I would say the best moment of
2023 I would
say uh you know after I filmed the last
uh the I this is off the top of my head
after I filmed the last uh show of the
special and I walked off to my family
best moment yeah I mean yeah it's up
there but what's the best let's say that
I I tend to really I tend to really
believe that the little moments are the
best yes you know so like I just like I
really like the just the regular
forgetful days that we just really live
our lives and spend time with the the
family I'm trying to really like cherish
that right that's I heard Jerry Seinfeld
the book to daily dad Jerry Seinfeld
talks about the garbage time he's like
you know people want always talking
about parents always talking about
quality time quality time which is
important but Jerry s's like I want the
garbage time with the kids I want the
time when you know we're not it's not a
mandated thing we're watching movie it's
like just time taking them to school all
time you know whatever at the dinner
table with them they're not even looking
at me like I want that time with them
too which is interesting yeah well why
do you ask uh and do you have yours I
mean is that just for no for just you
just trying to pinpoint well because
because I always every day I I you know
when my kids get out of school I ask
them the same questions I always ask
them one I was like what was the most
exciting moment of your day I like to
know that and I say what was the what
was this was there a scary part of your
day and what was the lowest part of your
day I don't just say how was school I
want to get like very specific with them
and my daughter and stepson used to say
like no dad that's too hard like I can't
it's too but now because we doing it
they always they think about like when
it happens they they're like oh my dad's
going to ask me so they always come in
now with kind of like wild and like
little kids like when you ask them that
specifically like their minds go to the
little things too like Dela said to me
once oh the best moment of my day is it
wasn't even you know it was still it was
cold out it was three weeks ago she's
like oh the wind I was walking in the
hallway and the wind blew my hair she
said that yeah she was like and I I I
that was made me feel good W that's
pretty cool you know and she wasn't like
oh you know she she's appreciating the
little things she's finding Beauty in
every day right which I think that's
that's the that's the biggest thing and
you know that for me the the it was it
happened like two months ago did I tell
you about the old lady outside the
coffee shop she lived in the shoe Liv in
the shoe yeah the old lady Liv in the
shoe Swallowed a Fly swallow a fly so
the old lady so I was sitting outside
farest coffee shop right I'm sitting
outside farest coffee shop allegedly
allegedly it's called farest Cafe fars
Cafe in Queens excellent place love it
great coffee great power um protein
bites that are like you know cocoa
almonds dates roll balls shout out power
in shout out power gingerbread uh pound
cake really uh amazing um so really good
stuff and uh just great people there so
anyway I'm did you invest in it no okay
I wish man I invested all my money in
Joey
roses uh you're not alone this has been
hey babe yeah so yeah Joey new location
opening up in Phoenixville
Pennsylvania opening up
online so no it's I think it's still
going Jo Rose is [__] unbelievable
slaming banging and Swinging sandwiches
are unbelievable I actually haven't had
a Jrs in a while I had one a couple of
weeks ago I didn't even tell Joey I just
went in there paid anonymously loved it
he does even know you did that no
because I support the biz because I do
genuinely love the sandwiches the best
tuna fish sandwich I've ever had in my
life at Joey roses yeah I actually might
want to go there and get the run the run
the table and maybe bring some home eat
them all yeah you know what's funny and
you can continue what you were going to
say I don't want to interrupt you say it
but I'm there's a go know what's funny
but just know that I'm I'm hoping to
laugh oh no it's not funny okay fine you
know you know what's you you have to go
to Joey roses and get the fat kit oh I
love the fat kit that's the one with the
peanut butter peanut butter jelly and
potato chips but like he didn't do
anything there really you know what I
mean but yes but he did but he did I I
love it it's the one Sam that's I always
think about from there even though I
like them all but it's it's funny cuz
it's Jarred it's just we have access to
it the bread makes a difference but also
he triple layers it that's the and it's
just fun it's like you know like when do
you sit down triple layer a PBJ and add
chips to it because also I think he did
two things there very smart one you're
right he did not reinvent the wheel what
he did though was number when do you
ever see peanut butter and jelly on a
menu it's like ordering a bowl of cereal
if you put bowls of cereal on the menu
people would order that all the time cuz
that's the thing you eat at home but Joe
said I'm going to put on the menu and
people order and then the sprinkle the
potato chips is and the three layers is
the extra acant that people like I'll
tell you what I used to you know run a
bar and we had a menu that started at
midnight and it was you know the
midnight menu a truncated you was the
midnight men and uh I we would have
input sometimes and I was like I'm
telling you I was like you put on a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich and you
can have the sides cut off or not the
crust cut off or not that's your option
it comes with a glass of milk and uh I
said that's going to be that's going to
be banging you could toast if you want a
PBJ and and you put on this menu and I
thought it was going to kill it no one
no one bought it no one bought it yeah
no one bought it well wrong clientele
yeah that's all it is yeah I just need
more like Skelly people from the Lowry
side Sky yeah or and you know the bar is
right next to a school get the kids
coming in order pbjs that's right kids
come on down to joeyy roses anytime it's
130 169 Rivington 139 I think it's it
171 169 1719 it's cross School uh get
they do not ID check um and you can get
peanut but and jelly there and play
games there it is it's 174 riving there
you go kids 174 riving stop Joey Rose's
social club and uh yes and it is a safe
space for Trans people you don't need
your
parents you don't need your parents and
um yeah um so you go if you go in and
you look the hard right there's a small
door if you go hard right or if you go
into to the back you can go past like
the curtains and then there's like a
little room with a meat slicer you'll
find Joey in one of those you'll find
Joey um okay so so best moment of of my
year Forest Cafe which I love farest
Cafe I'm sitting out there I was it was
it was it was about early November so it
wasn't warm it wasn't cold I was sitting
outside I had a Patagonia puffer on the
Nano puffer pagonia puffer Nano sitting
there i' got just it was a afternoon I
was got a cup of iced coffee black the
way I like it cold and black and I'm
sitting there drinking and it was
unbelievable took the first SI I was
like wow it hit me it was just beautiful
and I'm texting with Maddie Healey the
lead singer of The 1975 who's now become
a
friend s
stretching
s
you want to [__] tell me how that
happened when did that happen how do you
how do you not how do you how do I not
know that I know how do you when did
this happen how did it happen did you
manifest it was it by chance are you
really friends show me the text chain
okay like do you talk about cool stuff
or is it just like touch Bas so really
so what do you feel now have you seen
them for free did they give you a ticket
no just expound no same way I support
Joey roses I'll always support the 1975
bought a ticket what I did is I bought a
ticket bought ticket but then I got in
touch with him cuz we were dming and he
gave me his cell number said comforable
my life and gave me his cell number and
he said text me and he said text you
were dming why because he dm' me he dm'
me last year because I talked about on
Joe Rogan so he you talk you talk about
him on so he started dming and then he
gave me his phone number they came to
Madison Square Garden in November so I
went to go see the show and then I got
to meet him after the show but yeah that
that that's a text chain with them yeah
and so do you does he know he knows that
you this is the only band you really
listen to and he knows he knows all
about it he's a cool dude very cool guy
very very cool guy I mean I mean I said
here can I read one time I said this how
you know he's are you green or are you
gray I'm green how are you green because
he doesn't have an iPhone or oh oh right
so you're great I got you I said I said
um uh I said
uh he did a bit with this he put this
kid up he put up he put this kid up on
the Jumbotron and this kid Kaden he made
was on his Instagram and he did like
this really great thing for him like the
kid I think was sick or something and he
did something really nice and I said the
Kaden bid is classic great stuff man you
made his life because it was really cool
video and he goes he's so sweet I said I
teared up at the New York Sports Club my
boy was like what's wrong I said MADD is
at it again and he wrote so gay and I
wrote nobody gayer than me don't ever
forget that he wrote I'm English and in
the
1975 which I which I thought was amazing
which I thought that was an amazing text
when he said cuz he just knows who he is
and anyway so is he gay no no he's he's
gay like I'm gay like you know like you
know actually he lost Taylor Swift this
year he did Matty Healey and Taylor
Swift broke up and then but you know he
dated Taylor Swift Matty Hy was dating
Taylor Swift in the beginning of the
year that didn't come get to my desk so
Maddie and Taylor dating but whatever
but anyway I'm texting Maddy Healey and
and I'm like wow I was kind of having a
moment I was like look at where my
career I started listening to these guys
10 years ago and now I'm texting with
the lead singer we're having fun
whatever I'm like what what a beautiful
thing and I'm just sitting there
enjoying my daughter was at uh ballet
class my 2-year-old was was at my mom's
house taking a nap and I was sitting
there and this old woman comes up to me
91 years old she comes up to me and the
sun was like shining she was getting
vitamin D for sure she getting vitamin D
der something thermogenic was happening
yes and then she sits down she sits down
next to me doesn't you know at there was
room on the bench but she sits down next
to me and she goes she looks at me she
goes oh you have such beautiful teeth
honey and I was like oh thanks like no
one's ever said that and she was like do
you floss and I said I said not honestly
not regularly like not enough she's like
you have very nice teeth and I said yeah
and she goes she just starts talking to
me she goes how old are you I said I'm
39 years old she goes 39 you must be at
a point in your life where you think the
best days are behind you and I said um
yeah I feel that at times she goes you
know why you feel that right I said no
she goes because your youth is ending
your youth is is actually ending but the
best parts of your life I think are
beginning but she said but your youth is
over when you're 40 you're not youthful
and you can act youthful but your youth
is over you're now becoming mature adult
and I said wow I said no she doesn't
know you that well true I know I know as
I I ripped a fart
right and I said to her I said Okay and
she said um wow and she said I'm 91
years old she said I worked at a dental
dentist office for 25 years she goes
that's why I know your teeth you have
very nice teeth I was like thanks and
she was like
believe it or not the best years of my
life started in my 60s she goes if I
could go back to any decade she goes I'm
91 now if I could go back to any decade
I would pick my 60s she goes you believe
it believe it or not and I said I said
did you ask her about what what happened
to this well I said to her why she was
like because she said my children were
older it was the late 90s yeah she was
like my children were older she's like I
love criss cross right I love Cris cross
yeah she was like I was one of the
original uh That's So Raven had just
come out I was original Al qaa
and and she said so she says um she says
because my children were older she goes
I knew who I was she goes I was still
healthy in my 60s she goes and I just
felt like I had given all I had to this
world and I paid all my dues and every
day past that was just any day is a good
day and truly a blessing she was like
and I felt like that for a long time and
I said well do you miss
like you know your your kids being like
young and stuff cuz she was like cuz I
said I have young kids she goes no no I
don't miss that I miss me being young
she goes cuz now I'm old now I can tell
you that I'm old I feel my body old feel
my brain being old and she was like um
so I was like well do you have like any
advice for for me then and she was like
I would say that whatever you're feeling
whatever you want to do you absolutely
do it she goes and that includes love I
said I have like a you know partner and
kids she goes that includes love she
goes I think too many of us just stay in
relationships we don't really like and
we're we're doing things we don't really
like and we let all these opportunities
pass she goes and you're going to regret
it all she goes and I tell your wife the
same thing she said the number one thing
that you and your partner need to have
above all is you better be kind to each
other kindness is key she said that like
three times she goes kindness is key if
she's not being kind and you're not
being kind move on to the next
relationship kindness she oh and then
she told me kindness is the only real
currency of the world is you being kind
to others that's how you get paid and
you get paid back is kindness I swear to
I was just sitting there drinking coffee
texting mty Hy getting hard and she goes
kindness is currency and then I swear to
God I was feeling and she pissed herself
she pissed herself she was looking at me
and I said she like it was bugging me
out because her face her face looked
exactly exactly like my Aunt eileene
like exactly where I was like this looks
like my Aunt like this looks exactly
like my Aunt she's just same hairstyles
same face and then so we're talking and
she actually had a friend with her and
the friend went and got the coffee so
they come out and and I go um I say oh
you know thanks for the talk um I said
what was your name she go well this is
Sheila she goes this is my friend Sheila
we've been friends for 50 years she goes
and am ien and wow I swear to God my
hair stood on the back of my neck I was
like holy [__] I texted my ant
immediately I was like are you a
dead are you a dead are you a dead and
she was like I'm fine wow you got to
love it you got to love that so that
that was was the best moment of my 2023
is this woman telling me kindness is
currency and basically to cheat on my
wife
right we should all cheat be cheating on
each other right right right wow that's
I mean look when she's looking back she
knows what she should have done so
anything you want to that's what I was
getting at before to just eff it just do
whatever you want to do do whatever you
want to do which we know but like we
really do it like what if we just did
you ever think
about taking what you have budgeting
yourself for as long as you possibly can
right like rest of your life and then
just like not living above your means
quite the opposite being a little more
minimalist simplifying and then just
have every day for the rest of your life
free to do what you like that's what I
strive to do literally every day and
that's what I think about every day and
that's need to provide for your family
yeah but then cut to me going first
class on Emirates Airlines to go do a
show and
du but that's okay cuz you already flew
Southwest so you could feel like Joe de
ro and and and but that's what my that's
what my hope is for 2024 is to try to
live within my means and just say
because there is you know I got a bigger
family so it's like there is just a
certain cost that comes in with kids
going to school and mortgages and all
that that's what that's that's what you
got to you got to be like everything
else is just like you know like do the
work that we're doing here just to like
live free I I have been thinking about
that more no but what I mean is like
take everything that you have do you
have to do you think so soon just call
it we we stop I'm doing an audition for
what we I'm saying you just let me know
yes but you let me know when you you
show what should I do know you're a
veteran in that show what should I know
going into the
audition well I she didn't an audition
right so I couldn't help because they
wanted me to play myself right so but I
will tell you that the set was amazing
and all of them are so funny and so kind
and I had the it was like one of the
best dates did you do it in Toronto I
did do it in Toronto this is this is
where the Toronto yeah well I'm gonna
read they want me to I got lucky I was
in a scene with all of them at one time
I'm a fan so gilo yeah GMO
geroo yes but who's not a vampire or he
they turned him into a vampire but I
don't think he was born a vampire no no
no no he didn't know in the beginning
there there's a whole journey foro
you've seen every app uh not this season
I have not I've seen all the way up to I
think they're on season five do you
think I'm going to get the part I
actually really do you think it's in
there I really do believe it you told me
what it was and I could I I just know
you'd probably be I I'm excited to see
what you do all right you said you
prepared for it yesterday prepared for
it how did you prepare take us inside
okay okay I did uh I so take Inside the
Actor's mind so what I did was what I
did was you're playing it's auditioned
for a a role um you know a guy uh
playing like I'm like a the leader of
like a like a like a uh investment firm
yeah and I'm playing like a role Hancock
and Sons congratulations we finally got
it kudos to everyone around Hancock and
Sons and name synonymous with classical
men's fashion I guarantee you JFK bang
Marilyn Manson Marilyn Monroe I'm sorry
Marilyn Monroe and a Hancock and Suns
tuxedo that's how you know this is a
quality acquisition and let me tell you
something [__] kudos to the people at
the lbo team you guys deserve it
congratulations everybody wow
wow that's that's a significant amount
of lines no that that's SC that's a run
there one yeah and oh that's one and
then you get you're saying that all at
the same time G let me ask you a
question yes you know the guy that
always comes in the you know him he's uh
you know janitor you know his name Andy
or some [__] what's his name Andy I
think it is sure yeah what's his name
noberto [__] idiot if that's his name
whatever well listen to me he
every time he comes in and tries to dump
out my waist basket the guy has a
10-minute conversation so do me a favor
[__] fire
him can you do that I I guess I can goo
let me tell you something right here
this guy this little ding-dong right
here absolute partner material I promise
you this is good what do you think wait
wait so how much that is dialogue of
yours and how much you taken Liberty
that was that was that's the dialogue
we're [__] in there and everything
yeah yeah the cursing and and then they
told me on top of adlib they said adlib
dingdong all that ding-dong is is is is
a dialogue wow what do you think you
think you prepared for it meaning you
ran the lines you felt the lines I kind
of thought about the person place time
what is this guy thinking about
investment firm yeah you said Canon
Capital head of it he's I maybe shaved
and your hair is good for it though the
hair the suit jacket yeah he's a bit of
a douchebag um you know I think there's
some kindness behind him but he also
comes off like a dick but then people
genuinely like him but he's a bit of a
dick is this a recurring I think it's
one one or two yeah yeah okay wow I like
it so you think you think so if they
believable yes I do believe it and if
they say to you that was great take it a
different way or take it again then what
I would do is probably slow down okay or
go faster okay this been hey
[Laughter]
babe don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey Bab